it's great a scary
he was on the run he was almost this
godlike figure we were the first mystery
station to get him this was a turning
point for Venezuela I've covered the
process in Venezuela before in 2014 and
in 2017 they're coming from all over the
place
the opposition had always been
ineffective they've never had a leader
well at least not one who had stayed in
the country or hadn't been arrested all
of their various strategies before had
ended in terrible violence we'd witness
that there'd be waves of protests in
Venezuela for years now but there was a
sort of feeling of resignation amongst
opposition supporters that they lost the
battle in this instance things have
changed
there seem to be more hope and a belief
that something was on the cusp of change
what was different about this was the
sort of sudden emergence of the leader
Fran glider
and that did change the dynamic on
streets we do a completely unrelated
story in in Brazil Gustavo our excellent
local producer in Venezuela had been
sending us messages saying you guys
really need to keep an eye on Venezuela
then would be a potential for a
revolution if you like who is it going
to be this announcement of the fair a
new person who's calling for enormous
rallies on the street and that that was
going to be the setting for something we
know what it was first day we were there
we actually just went for a drive
reports of violence everywhere already
so we're heading out with a bit of
trepidation to be honest the first group
we came across were just putting up
barricades on the motorways this is how
they usually start there's certain
violent confrontations inevitably
followed this
the west of the city going towards the
presidential palace tear gas fires we
people being killed this is going to be
chaotic the danger day is that it keep
quickly escalate
the protesters were pushing forward
there was tear gas being fired
so be firing bird shot they'll be
detaining people you have to be very
very careful and you don't have much
protection
I knew that I had to be pretty and then
just get back
we went in undercover in Venezuela so we
didn't have gas masks we only had
motorcycle helmets they're firing
teargas they're firing rubber bullets
you have to just assess the risk level
as you go along every moment one of the
main methods from the protesters was
actually closed roads one should those
roads are closed and people are out
protesting you can't actually get
through it in a car
both stealing gas Davao was said the
best way for us to get around is on
motorcycles you're agile you're fast you
can move to traffic if something happens
you leave quickly
keep going keep going you can shoot
things discreetly such as security
forces on the side of the road but you
should just drive past them before they
we noticed you were there you've got a
shot you just blend in you know you're
wearing a helmet as far as anybody else
is concerned you're just another
Venezuelan on your motorcycle going
about your business you can't describe
your film because someone will stop you
and as the journalist who's there
without journalist credentials you will
be in trouble you would detained and you
will be deported if not worse with us
home please they take time off work and
they work as a agency they know the
roads they know the back roads they know
how to avoid traffic they know which
police to avoid they know how to avoid
the National Guard everyone has to make
some money in Venezuela that's what they
do
these rise for the first time that iousy
were absolutely fast
just like a sea of people literally
miles of people going down some of the
main boulevards being the center of
practice there's hundreds of thousands
of people on the street the atmosphere
was absolutely paid I mean hundreds upon
hundreds and thousands of people in
Caracas and different cities around
Venezuela that believes that they were
about to get new Messiah the people at
these protests certainly fed up with
Maduro regime it's been 20 years of
these and hopefully this will be the
year though this wasn't one in as you
can see nobody's giving up people are
looking forward for this change the
regime is gotta fall our justice be they
were going to show people that this is
Venezuela this is Omar the future
I was quite astounded by how positive is
lots of kids are the very bottom you
know quite old and quite young that his
time is up although he steadfastly
refusing to say or even act as if it is
they came out in their national colours
there was a real sense of unity amongst
opposition supporters in those first few
days they thought you know we're really
on the cusp of a massive change here
I think they expected the Maduro
government to fall almost every person
you spoke to was just sort of wide-eyed
and faith smiled and saying look at this
can you believe it and there was a lot
of belief that this was a turning point
for Venezuela you believe it's the
beginning
we've never been as strong as room
Venezuelans are very proud of their
country they would sing the national
anthem and it was like that at every
rally when you hear that national anthem
that is the sense of unity and hope that
you draw from it it was sung with the
same passion in the same heart
I remember watching these two women who
were standing side by side and they were
singing with all their heart and in
crying at the same time they believed in
the future of their country very little
is known about him he's the leader of
the National Assembly people here you
know really have thrown their weight
behind him on this day he stood on stage
who took the oath and he declared
himself president
[Applause]
so mean for Roman telecom bodacious then
he will be honest you know
[Applause]
from that moment it's almost exactly
what his support is needed they needed a
leader it'd be immediately recognized by
the United States government and
suddenly we had this massive figurehead
we were like sardines squashed in the
crowd as people went crazy and we saw
this man sort of coming with the crowd
[Applause]
that's quite out the Assumption in those
two minutes was that somebody's gonna
come arresting or shooting you came
swarming through the crowd towards us
and the people were absolutely ecstatic
it was just a stream of people and
sister crying his name on my finger
touch
[Applause]
he was almost like this godlike figure
who had suddenly become part of the
crowd and at one point a woman fell over
in in the crowd to Romania and he helped
her onto her feet in that moment we
thought ok I think we know what this guy
is all about no vidiots had these
close-up shots before because beer just
emerged many here believe should be
President greeting him on the streets
when I'll actually finally get to speak
to glider had it perfectly framed up
this is a prisoner and Dan this
literally lifted in the air and rode out
of the back it was one of his security
guys and I was the Satan payment we're
doing an interview the bodyguards
remember are worried because they just
don't know who's in the crowd the crowd
went crazy because they've got this sort
of new Messiah and you've got them
having to keep moving in because they're
worried about safety Dan and Gustavo
were being thrown all over the place I'm
a naked face of Gustavus huge movie
games pretty difficult it's very hard to
hold chemistry in there pushing out the
way are the cameramen are pushing from
the side some of the best shots we've
had have come from our campus of quite a
light next to them without those shots
then the story doesn't come alive after
the first few times seeing Guido at his
rallies I said I don't know what it is
but he reminds me of Barack Obama it's
like wow
Latin Barack Obama he has a real man of
the people stuff
he also then started doing that yes we
can
[Applause]
find the addresses crowd and it's
absolutely enormous stretches as far as
the eye can see down the street when
they go absolutely crazy it became much
more rock star
[Applause]
a few days after the first rally a
one-way door went to church with his mum
and with his wife it was a quiet moment
for people to experience a different
side of the man aside that's away from
the loud noise and the rockstar figure
that he is in the crowds but seeing a
more thoughtful man here's a mother
whose son has the courage to take on
what he's taken on and is a wanted man
this was a moment where he probably he
and the family realized everything has
changed
we talked to him afterwards Stewart
asked him you've taken on a lot I mean
don't you worry about your safety you
know your safety your wife's safety your
mother's safety your little baby safety
and he said yes of course I worry I mean
I'm just a family man but others have
suffered way more and others continue to
suffer and if this is the price I have
to pay then so be it he was on the run
their first instinct would have been to
arrest him for days we'd been trying to
get one quite oh the tension around his
safety and security is a very real thing
so where were they thinking they're
moving from safe house to safe as almost
constantly and so we eventually
buttonhole his sort of main press guy
and we got a call and he said right you
have an interview with him today we just
told it to be in a certain part of town
so we drive around
tried calling no answer try calling no
answer no answer I'll keep thinking well
I stick out like a sore thumb and at
this stage we were quite exposed it
looks a bit dodgy and we then get
another call to go to another place so
we go there and then another call to go
to another place and so finally we go
inside and sort of taking into the lift
by as a tool minder e time is it all a
community yeah they have to be hiding
because we are in a dictatorship so we
have to take care of him very jumpy
very word and so you do have that sense
of trepidation
we waited outside the door waited waited
and the door open and we walked and
there he was he's signing pieces of
paper and he's stamping things and it's
like you're walking into a presidential
office he also looked like he had a lot
on his mind
no sir I'm in tennis I'm in Deloitte
ausonian okay again from the mayor
Internationale basically saying is we
need international support we can
achieve this but we can't do it alive I
said do you expect to get arrested he
said he thought he might do but that
this was almost if you like a sort of
destiny there like I was I am okay I see
really good at that why didn't they
arrest him one of maduro's deputy a
woman said at the moment he's a nothing
if we arrest him he becomes a world hero
[Music]
we weren't sure what the response to us
might be at the Maduro government
batteries
initially we shied away from going
simply because I'm our status in the
country we didn't necessarily want to
draw attention to ourselves but we went
and we experience the same warmth that
we had at the opposition rallies people
were very happy to talk to us people
were very happy to tell us why they
support Maduro those people in large
numbers dreadfully poor but still
incredibly supportive of the system
because they actually believed in it
there's not a lot of people within their
Maduro supporters who would like a
change of government but they would
likely to be far more extreme but much
more socialist they felt that all he was
trying to do was trying to continue Hugo
Chavez legacy madura is the head of a
system and they have is based on the
military in the police
they run everything this isn't a matter
of the military or security services
changing sides they are all the sides
the system is there and then you
actually have the original colectivos as
they're called supporters the cheers to
revolution and are still a lot of the
colectivos are civilians enabled by the
government to keep law and order and
keep control
now some do that through educational and
community outreach type of projects but
their most known for their armed militia
wing which instills a lot of fear and a
lot of discipline amongst communities
they're really the enforcers they're
there to make sure that people stay in
line they can be extremely violent they
are above the law people can be taken
away in the middle of the night they can
be shot they can be killed bodies can be
dumped
they're dangerous man if you get on the
wrong side of them in any neighborhood
you go into there'll be colectivos
keeping a lookout for strangers and they
know if you're strained especially if
you look the way we do and they'll be
keeping a lookout for people with
cameras
the United States early are pledged aid
to Venezuela as long as the aid was
delivered to the opposition
the age started becoming a political
tool you can focus the world attention
on an evil government refusing a to its
own people when it desperately needs aid
but Venezuela Colombia border became the
potential flashpoint so it deployed to
another team cuz you didn't know what
was there how volatile is going to be
they saw the tear gassing the crowds
going back and forth
the National Guard on the other side
refusing to let anyone move and to say
it was not great successful beard
understatement it did nothing good for
the opposition at all
wider was being investigated as the
speaker of national assembly and as a
member of the master sembly you have
immunity from prosecution he has a
travel ban so he's not actually allowed
to leave the country but he managed to
sneak out and appeared on the other side
and then was rated by various leaders
around South America held a series of
talks the problem for him is that
support at home drifted away almost
instantly and the question we enter eyes
will he or won't he come back and then
he turns up at the Apple and just landed
and breezed through passport control off
he went and he came to the rally where
we were that was a big thing finally be
come back because he was losing momentum
and he was back fine labs have been
allowed to continue with their rallies
then the lights went off
electricity power cut brought about a
massive sudden rethink for the
government the power outage to us seemed
like the most significant thing to hit
murderers government electricity carries
on all weather actually things get even
even worse the power going off the water
going off everything going off and
staying off and staying off and staying
off its grip and he's scary
nothing was working at all the water is
brought to houses by pumping and in
order to pump you need electricity so
there's no water this is really bad the
government as soon as it was able to
said that this was of the United States
plot or was it just Maduro as government
doing its usual thing of blaming America
for everything that goes wrong in this
country when actually it's just bad
management it spooked the population
that have never had losses like that
and so people were going to desperate
measures they were taking water from the
river and the river is very polluted I
mean it was a recipe for disaster and I
was filming one day and I saw people
serve in a hole they'd uncovered like
old water pipes and there was found a
little leak and relate to collecting the
water people are drinking from sewers
we're staying in a nice hotel that the
way that the upper classes particularly
the Maduro supporting upper classes to
deal with the blackout and a water
shortage was to promptly put themselves
into a five-star hotel I decided to just
wander around and see what was going on
now the whole of the city is got low
power and there is a wedding taking
place and I'd have walked through the
various bars full of the glitterati of
the Maduro society including the
families of military generals we're told
that was sort of indicative to me of a
system that really is basically corrupt
you know they didn't know how to deal
with actually just having a power cut
this could be a game-changing moment
forget the politics side of it so that
the power struggle is actually a power
cut
you know where are we left now is there
any major change the things need to
change they have to change because
there's a lot of people that are really
suffering Venezuela as long as the
military continues to support president
Maduro there's no way that the
opposition can take control of the
country the pro Maduro Constituent
Assembly as it's called has recently
stripped quiter of his immunity and so
there is a distinct possibility that he
too will end up in jail
the sense we got was their determination
to keep getting out on the streets
people who want change will continue to
fight for that change particularly
because things have gotten a lot more
desperate and they have no other choice
really millions have left millions more
are predicted to leave those who have
stayed seem absolutely determined
however long it takes it could take me
another 20 years
but they determined to
[Applause]
[Music]